welcome back to the break we have dakota
adams
um stuart rhodes
the founder of the oath keepers who is
charged with seditious conspiracy
um in a u.s federal court
dakota here is
stewart rhodes estranged son uh thank
thanks for joining us dakota uh there's
a lot of news dropping uh we are
recording this uh this afternoon this is
the afternoon of the the 16th wednesday
the 16th
um it's about uh
six o'clock uh eastern standard time
just to give people kind of a stamp of
where we're at um there's a lot of news
dropping today there was a hearing today
um stewart's
attorneys were trying to get to where he
is released from pre-trial detention
um did you guys listen to this to any of
this hearing or are you just seeing some
of the threads what how how are you guys
finding the back of the twitter live
threads
um i was away at work and didn't and did
not dial in
um so people in my family dialed in and
listened in on the media line
okay so they so they were so they were
listening because it seemed like your
mom tasha was actually listening in on
the line
as it was happening okay um so what is
your understanding of exactly what the
the ruling is here i know the judge is
probably going to delay their ruling but
what is your understanding of some of
the evidence not only that is uh
stewart's lawyer and steward is trying
to make to to get out of pre-trial
detention but what is some of the
arguments for keeping him in pre-trial
attention i know we talked about this
before but what's your understanding
from what you've heard so far
um
the crux of his argument is that he did
not make a run for mexico or try to
start an insurgency
that people know of
um after january 6
and this demonstrates that he is not a
flight risk because he didn't he didn't
run but at the time it looked like he
wasn't going to get arrested or the
wheels were turning very slowly
so if it looks like he's going to be in
serious trouble then yes flight risk but
he still thinks he can beat the rap and
get a ton of attention for it
so you you do believe that stewart is
still a flight risk yes if it starts
starts to look like the trial is going
badly for him
that's when he will disappear and become
immediately very dangerous because the
for stewart the next best option
after
um beating the rap like several of the
people at bundy ranch and malhora did
the next best option is starting
a civil war
because that
person like on on a personal scale the
chances of being on the winning side of
the civil war or coming out of it okay
for him personally his odds are better
than if he just surrendered and went to
prison because then he's in prison so
this this is his thought process right
yes right i mean some of this stuff is
delusion right i mean you believe some
of this is delusion that he's that he's
making some of this stuff up that you
know well he's definitely got the uh
the uh savior of america complex right
but the uh yeah the whole crux of the
argument is basically that
you can rely on his klingon sense of
honor
the fact that he's been a relatively
good boy in the sense that he has not um
orchestrated a second terrorist attack
since the first one right yes well you
know you know one one one is better than
none right and two is way worse i mean
how many can you add right
how many how many can you actually do in
your lifetime right you know like the
fact that you'd ever do more than one is
kind of crazy but right or one at all
then for that matter so
you brought up the bundy ranch which
which we talked about this last time we
had you on
you are under the assumption that the
reason why um stuart rhodes the founder
of the oath keepers who is diametrically
opposed to
um an insurrection or instituting an
insurrection act or using martial law to
take over the government as that would
be a coup
um which that was kind of their you know
their credo with or part of the credo
with oath keepers they did a 180 flip
and they've done this flip and you
you're you made assumptions that it had
to do with his
um maybe his activity at bundy ranch do
you do you think that that is still some
of that stuff that bunny ranch is still
playing a role in what how he's trying
to manage this whole situation oh it
absolutely is because he saw that uh
people who had criminal charges and
bunny ranch many of them
who refused a plea deal
managed to get acquitted and walk away
or get very light sentences when the
people who took plea deals early on
uh generally made out worse and then the
same thing happened at malheur in the
end the male hue or the charters were
thrown out because there was so many
paid informants
inside the compound at the end of the
standoff
that made it look like really unclear as
to whether there was entrapment going on
or not
right and you've seen these and he's
learned from the example
so he's going to try to write it out but
if it looks like it's going badly for
him
that's when the switch is going to flip
right and that's and that's probably why
the federal judge is going to keep him
in detention i really hope so because
that's uh
it's worrying me a lot but back to you
just really quickly so let's say that
the judge says okay you know what you
you're not a flight risk and will let
you out of you know pre-trial detention
uh
i guess in that scenario what happens
right like where does like does he have
to stay
like under surveillance like i guess
like how does that he would be
under supposedly under surveillance he
would be staying with custodians
to basically uh us basically sponsors
for him
is one way to think of it like okay
sponsor visa out of jail
and but the people he's staying with
from looking at the twitter threads i'm
pretty sure these are
um relatives of his who are rabidly pro
oath keepers
and completely ideologically in lockstep
with him so they wouldn't if he was
going to do any more terroristic [ __ ]
they wouldn't be monitoring him at all
they'd be placing him with sympathizers
seems kind of odd that they would kind
of put the trust faith and trust into a
relative as opposed to a third party
who's well they were supposedly
apolitical
relationship
anyone really a political right yeah
very boring and not involved with
anything
but
it turns out that
their social media is nothing but health
keepership i see that's a red flag but
yeah yeah
especially when he was the founder of
the oath keepers and they were doing it
doing this seditious conspiracy in in
the in the uh in the way of officially
with the oath keepers so that that
brings us to part of the argument that
um
i think i think that fell apart pretty
quickly was the timing of ashley babbitt
being shot that was a very strange thing
to bring up
because the timeline is only off by a
few minutes but it's off by an amount
that it can't possibly make any sense
right
yeah that was a very odd attack i mean
it would it would make sense if time
travel was involved because you'd have
to go back eight minutes or whatever to
to know that it was going to happen to
then take action in a preemptive or
premeditated way
i'm
i can't wait for the conspiracy theories
to start popping popping up around this
people are saying that this is evidence
that the shooting of ashley about it was
a planned false flag again oh jesus
christ
i bet money on it well you know i i
don't doubt you that that the crazy can
get crazier because uh there's clear
evidence just just on twitter you can
find it pretty pretty easily with
timestamps um
there's a video and i think i actually
sent it to you to see what your thoughts
were there's a video
where the oath keepers appear in the
rotunda
and i'm not sure who they are it's hard
to make it out because it's not a very
it's a very fast video but they are
obviously wearing vest and uniforms that
say oh with the oath keepers patch on it
um and i'm not sure if one of them is
steward or not a lot of it's at the
backs of those people that are standing
there in the video no i don't believe
stewart ever went into
into the building
do you think do you think is there any
evidence that you've found so far in
your search that there was orders given
i mean is that i mean there has to be
something because there's something to
this um
the the the what is it called quick
reaction force qrf is that what it's
called there's something to that um
where stewart was stashing these weapons
apparently
they were going to take a boat across
the potomac if the bridges were sealed
off
by copser national guard
um they were
um ready and waiting and
they were the qrf people were dinging
stewart's phone
over signal asking for confirmation that
was time to go in
while he was giving his situation report
from just outside the capitol
um talking about how
mobs of patriots had just reached the
building and they were banging banging
on different doors and was basically uh
live tweeting it out to his people while
his qrf team was repeatedly asking if it
was go time yet
right so what you're saying is there's
several teams of people here this is
very strategic and tactical this wasn't
haphazard no this wouldn't happen at all
this was pretty well this is pretty well
planned
they were i think really they were going
to try to get into a fight with any
counter protesters to create a smoke
screen
but they also talk a lot about
it like implying they're going to force
trump's hand
like if he's not going to do this we
will and they're going to
like present the taking of the capital
to the white house at to trump as they
to come play if that's how you if that's
how you pronounce it but he would never
have
like if
the interaction act isn't going to get
involved because there's no antifa here
then we just got to do it ourselves
so they have to instigate yes
going to instigate to give
trump
room
to invoke the insurrection act right
so it sounds like it sounds like um to
be honest by you saying it like that
that oath keepers um stewart maybe
specifically was way more desperate for
donald trump to remain president than
maybe even donald trump
he was absolutely desperate for donald
trump for in president because he was
terrified of hillary clinton being
elected
specifically because it could mean
uh him getting charged for
uh his role in bundy ranch because those
are still crimes that they hadn't
prosecuted them for yet
but they could have and that's something
that happened after mal hewer is
people didn't go to prison mostly over
the maoku or standoff
the people that were in amen bundy's
inner circle went to prison for bundy
ranch-related charges
that were filed and they were arrested
for under the cover of the malheur
incident right
so what what is it what is it about
bundy ranch that that has stewart
worried i mean is there a specific event
or is it just the way
the way that he's seen other people
treated um that were charged and stuff i
mean is there something specific
his involvement
for a talk with the fbi especially after
the sugar after the sugar pine mine
stand off as well
all keepers was involved with but he
took um
food medical communications
and multiple tactical teams with actual
combat veterans that were well organized
and not lunatics in the desert with guns
like many of the other militiamen that
showed up for bundy ranch
the most organized
group there
was oath keepers and their affiliates 33
and they were the only ones that even
thought about the back end like
sanitation or running water
right like definitely keep it prolonged
right i mean yes you're not gonna
prolong stuff with without having
sanitation or water i mean and that's
where i've seen people referencing that
they had also had 30 days of food
stashed nearby in virginia
so you're you're saying you're saying
separate from the bunny ranch the
insurrection that there possibly could
have been this some of the same type of
preparations made yeah because
everything everything they do
as far as operations go is a stewart
sometimes has really weird and
inexplicable behaviors but he
understands
the importance of logistics
and supply
and demand right he's not going to just
haphazardly do something he's going he's
not one of these guys that's just going
i've got a bunch of guns that's the
right of my preferences
is he one thing he does that i got to
give him credit for ron is
look at it as a full spectrum thing yeah
so as far as the the qrf and some of
these tactical teams because you know
some of this uh from being kind of
uh stewart's teenage sidekick i think as
you said as you said in our last in our
last video
a lot of different events yes so
um so explain
explain to people what that means
because you know we are oath keepers and
there's 10 people charged you know you
know it people don't quite understand
exactly uh that mentality like you're
talking about and not only that the
organization and how
how they manage these events with the
quote unquote logistics like you said
either for weapons food
supplies so so explain
why it would be important to have these
different teams one that would go inside
the building one that would be with the
qrf
maybe some other team somewhere else i
mean what makes that such a tactical
advantage if if they were trying to
force trump's hand or trump was trying
to do the insurrection act as some have
assumed in this case based on the
documents that are in court that they're
charged with the seditious conspiracy
well
the obvious thing is that the first team
that goes on to the capital grounds
would eventually breach the capital they
are unarmed with as far as guns go
but still carrying um like
i think like like hardens
hardened punching gloves and body armor
and so they are they are they have some
sort of weaponry just right firearms
they're armed in some way
yeah but they're uh they're very
deliberately not carrying guns because
then the capitol police realize this
and they get caught with guns then the
lid comes off way too early right and
you can actually see some of where it
works out as a tactic in the uh video of
the mob being confronted by eugene
goodman
um you're talking about where he's
running up the stairs and trying to kind
of kind of coax the crowd into a certain
area yeah when they
initially confront him
he's got his hand on his pistol and the
this crowd of people with with their
flagpoles and their baseball bats is
advancing on him
holding their hands up going we're
unarmed don't shoot or the people in
front are and then right behind them are
the people with the flagpoles and the
baseball bats
and it's and it's the calculus that
they're forcing is
do you stop this mob
with a single well placed shot or and
then give them
the martyrdom of you just shot an
honorary patriot
yeah right in the middle of this protest
and also you're probably about to die if
you shoot someone if right i was going
to say that's the other side is like the
in the first thing that comes to mind is
like you know in zombie movies when
you're up against a crowd and you're
like i get a couple shots off i get some
but the the massive people is
overwhelming
and you know now you've you know
potentially gotten yourself killed and
that weapon
is up in their arms so yeah they were
some of the officers on the outside
there were
almost said protesters that shows how
pervasive the messaging is rioters who
were trying to
tackle them and take their pistols
right well so so to be fair with that
language because um we've talked to a
couple of people that were actually on
the capitol grounds that day um
that were actually just filming for
satire right
and the
they they've seen it a couple different
ways there were protesters there there
were writers there there were
insurrectionists there and there were
people with way more deep-seated uh um
conspiracy as it were to do this and and
the the reason why i say that is because
if you watch the ashley babbitt video
speaking of someone getting shot um and
an officer taking the shot if if they
needed to thinking you know doing the
calculus as you were saying um when when
ashley babbitt is shot in that video
um there is a tactical team that is
moving up the stairs which was directly
behind her um when they move up those
stairs they're wearing uniforms they're
carrying weapons obviously um what what
i find funny is
the oath keepers and other tactical
groups were moving the same way into the
capital but not for the same reason that
those teams were um
can you
because it really is weird to watch some
of the video where the oath keepers are
almost look like official military maybe
even national guard at some point and
they're moving in certain ways trying to
work through the crowd they have their
hands on shoulders and that's going to
keep people from getting separated in
the press in the press of the crowd it
makes it easier to force your way
through
you don't get you don't get your columns
split apart
but they
were going in to do something very
specific once they saw that it was
already and this is the thing about it
that really sums up the uh logic of the
whole thing
is they're operating inside a chaotic
incident that creates noise and gives
them cover and they didn't reach the
capitol until the doors were already
busted down
and then they moved in
in their stack and made their way
through the crowd and i've seen some
people saying that they went directly to
nancy pelosi's office right so so when
you say stack you that's what that's
when they're moving up the stairs
so they don't get lost right right and
then and then you're saying you're
saying when you move that way and you
actually enter a building that's already
open because maybe someone is was
incited and enraged to go open it for
you right like you know just
happenstance right yeah that is the
other that is the other thing is
that's all circles just a little bit all
the way back to the uh bail hearing
is
not since january 6 has there been a
large chaotic event where oath keepers
could try to pull something
under the smoke screen
of a massive riot or protest
right well and and uh you know they've
tried to have several sense like in
commemoration almost
of of their
you showed up for yes right right well
and we have this um this thing going on
at the canadian border which seems to be
start starting to head down the road of
almost the same kind of direction well
i'll tell you exactly what that is if
but um if you
have uh you had something you're
somewhere you were going uh talking
about the stack before we get off topic
yeah sure go ahead
well um i i think i think that that
all's i was trying to do with the stack
is that the tactical team that was doing
the stack ins inside the building they
had a purpose um you were saying earlier
that there is a team with the qrf
those guys had guns and live ammunition
they were across the river in virginia
where it's not illegal to carry military
power weapons they were at the hotel
they were ready to go at a moment's
notice if they got word that they were
being called into dc
but the noticeable thing is the qrf guy
isn't asking whether trump has invoked
the insurrection act yet when he's
messaging stewart on signal
he's not
he's not saying that he's got his eyes
glued to the tv to see an announcement
from the white house that trump was
invoking insurrection act
what he's who he's asking for permission
to get active and go in is stuart rhodes
so stuart would actually give the order
is what you're saying yeah he was asking
stuart
for the order to go in repeatedly in
these signal chats and not mentioning
that it was conditional
on the say so of trump and the official
seal of approval i think that would have
been ideal
but i don't think it was necessary for
their plan there just wasn't enough
chaos for them to carry off whatever
they actually wanted to do
right it also makes a case for the fact
that like they're you know you could i
guess under uh
under a defense say well if you know
there was actually mention of trump then
maybe there's like misconception or
belief that he was the person but since
he was requesting permission from
specifically
stewart
no one else or no other condition for
stuart to say the go-ahead then it does
put in place like okay stewart was
in some ways you know the outside eyes
at the capitol that was kind of
the head of the operation right yeah
he was in a scene like a scene like an
emergency service was like a scene
commander's position
he wouldn't go in because that would put
himself at risk and if he's gone then
obviously whoever the number two or
number three is
would then you know
take up rank but if he goes in and risks
his life then no one is there to give
the go-ahead from the outside and this
also keeps
the plausible deniability up a little
bit further which is how he got away
with things in the past is maintaining a
little bit of distance right because i
remember you mentioned that uh in the
interview with your mom about how
before
until this point you know stuart was
very very specific about when or where
they would do stuff like the proud boys
would go in and they were always on the
front line and they would get all the
media attention but the oath keepers
would not and the only reason that he
would have actually done something like
enter into the capitol or or send in
people into the capital was that there
was a sure thing he thought he had a
sure path
to
at the very least an outcome that
doesn't see him in prison
and going off of hit like the
photographs of him with michael flynn
that same day
i'd be willing to bet a lot that he was
in communication
with people who were in communication
with the white house and there's there
he was being
real probably relayed
updates
went through loop and
once they go into the capital and start
like searching offices
like
it's clear that there's not antifa there
so you just have to make as much chaos
as possible yourself right to push the
envelope and see if you can create
enough chaos for
for them
for that for that switch the flip
because what you're saying is and and
this was going to lead me to my next
um lines of questions here is that
stuart was in charge of giving orders to
the qrf and the people that were
entering the capitol but there had to
have been someone
that was
relaying that message back to him of
when to give those orders right like
if the idea if the idea is that you are
gonna wait for a certain event or a
certain position to where you have the
backing of a certain person um that
would give you cover right that would
give you cover for whatever
seditious thing that you might be doing
whether you're doing it under the guise
of martial law and the insurrection act
you would have to have communications
coming from somewhere
i believe that that is what we're going
to see as the conspiracy because if the
government my view of it is that if the
government really believed that it's
just these oath keepers
inside this planning they would have
just charged them with sedition
but because it's a conspiracy it means
it goes outside the bounds of those
those people inside that
who were also unwrapped up more firmly
because he was involved in the planning
and execution of it a lot but he didn't
do anything personally himself
right right
so so what you're saying is you are
right i think they're going to try to
yank people that he was in communication
with
that were setting things up behind the
scenes
and you're talking about you're talking
about higher than what stewart was um
you know because we see the rolling
stones report from several months ago
that members of congress were were
bartering
pardons um for some of this
conspiracy work that that seems to be uh
the longer we go on here the more we see
that this conspiracy how this conspiracy
was playing out and possibly that the
members of congress there were members
of congress that were bartering with the
administration and with other groups
to trade chaos for pardons um we even
seen the president the former president
of the united states the cheeto dust
mobster grandpa poopy pants himself
donald j trump stand on stage a couple
weeks ago and even promise again give a
false you know it's all [ __ ] because
he promised you know i'm sure he
promised he pardoned these people before
that's why he's saying it now i don't
understand why these people are still
protecting some of these [ __ ]
because i i mean frankly if he wanted to
pardon stuart rhodes
he would have pardoned him before
january 20th
2021
well at that time it wasn't in the cards
because uh trump was mostly just angry
that these people failed him so he's
gonna leave him hanging out to dry just
like he's just just like he refused to
uh pay giuliani it's like failed me why
would i bother with you anymore yeah
right i mean that makes sense because
trump you know trump does take things
personally right like it's a personal
insult you didn't say this you didn't do
this you didn't whatever and i take it
as a personal event that like you're
attacking me
so it makes sense but yeah it's like you
know to tony's
it's literally two weeks but yeah
whatever plays to his face
well yeah yeah well definitely
the tail is wagging the dog at this
point for sure yes yes absolutely and i
think it's been that way for maybe
longer than we realize um you know but
that's i think that's definitely one
thing he can't let go of is the vaccine
thing because he sees that as one of his
personal accomplishments
right he can't let go of taking credit
for the vaccines even though it doesn't
play well
because it conflicts with his own
personal sense of narcissism exactly
yeah well i was i've said it to tony
before i was like that his his own ego
and narcissism will never let anyone
else take credit for something if
there's one thing he can leave office
with to say like this is my big
milestone accomplishment
that's the only thing he really has
and if he were to allow anyone else like
any one person any group entity to take
credit away from then it would totally
just destroy the image that he had you
know this legacy of the person who's you
know was able to save the pandemic or
whatever right um
but you know
any credit at all
yeah any chance he'll take it any chance
he can get so so that brings me to uh
some final thoughts here is because um
obviously if stuart rhodes were to get
out on the streets people like me and
gabe are not and are not in such
immediate danger but speaking of trump
and his supporters and the tail wagging
the dog it is possible that people that
um that are close to steward or have
been close to steward or have spoke out
or have given the authorities um
information that would lead the the
authorities prosecutors and judges to
believe that hey he is a flight risk um
what kind of if if the judge were to
decide on friday which it seems like
that's not going to be the case but that
the judge were to decide on friday to
release stuart from pre-trial detention
what kind of danger do you think that
puts not only you and your your mom but
maybe some of the other people that were
closest to her close to you guys in it
puts us and that really there
everyone would be in extreme danger
on a shorter or longer time scale
depending on how things play out so one
of the first things that would happen is
he would start trying to probably
arrange having a visitation with his
children for the first time in
i think two years now well over two
years
and the just to look good for the court
which means he'd be around them
right
physically
and the real danger is if he is
has access to the kids
when it looks like the trial is going
bad because i think the trial is not
going to go very well for him
and when it looks like the trial is
going against him is where he's going to
get unstable
and become an immediate danger to his
family
so it seems like you've experienced
this before when he's kind of painted
into a corner he gets yeah when he's
pinned into a corner he loses his
goddamn mind okay
well and that and that's probably part
of the reason why
bundy ranch
um and all this leading up to like
you're saying why he felt like he might
have been painted in the corner if per
se joe biden would become the president
united states just like he was terrified
of hillary clinton
that create the the white house is no
longer hostile to a federal
investigation of right-wing groups like
oath right right which is kind of a
delusion because the white house i mean
to most degrees doesn't
they don't really control like everyday
fbi investigations right i mean i mean
obviously they're briefed on them and
they know about them but they're not
making these day-to-day decisions on who
to indict what evidence is being
collected this isn't like the president
united states is shifting through the
evidence of the bundy ranch in the oval
office i mean this is kind of god he has
to do other things as you know the
president you know if you've got an
administration that's sympathetic to you
or at least is playing to a base
sympathetic to you they could put
pressure on the fbi and the department
of justice
right right
and that's and that's his game plan
right that's his game plan is to get the
best situation that he possibly can for
the fears that he would suffer
consequences um just the same way he's
doing today in this in this hearing so
what is your opinion to close out here
what is your opinion on on the what you
know about what was said today at the
hearing what you know about this judge
because it seems like you've done a
little bit of research on on this judge
of what decisions they made so what is
your opinion what do you think decision
that this judge is going to make on
friday
maybe you hope that he's going to think
is going to be held pending his trial i
think his spell is going and his appeal
for bail is going to be denied
and it's
because
they completely failed to address the
escape tunnels thing that was cited in
the original ruling
um they
failed to explain why this does this
custodial family would be able to
properly monitor him despite being
ideologically loyal to his cause
right
um
and their arguments around the specifics
of why stewart is not flight risk
are
kind of weak
right i think yeah
they really didn't prove that
like they didn't really make a strong
case for why the initial decision would
have been flawed
right
well i i i think you're correct there
that that even even in the lead up to
this hearing their arguments um in the
actual briefing um was flimsy at best um
with the ashley babbitt timeline thing
going on
basically in a lie right there yeah and
the custodial the custodial family thing
that's also an implicit lie because
right i believe the way it went down was
the husband testified so in other words
it's easy but this stuff is easy to
verify this stuff is easy to hear
is a huge
my father's cousin huge uh
huge oath keepers fan
i got you well so that that actually one
one more thing because that brings up
some another question in my mind of
speaking of oath keepers and fans and
going on nah this kelly's so real
character that has placed herself in the
story um she was running for a seat for
the state legislature apparently that's
what she was saying publicly she is no
longer running for that seat i guess um
she like self-proclaimed her self the
leader of the oath keepers she was
posting a lot of um
not just uh pro oath keepers but a lot
of
to be frank racist [ __ ] on her on her
twitter feed um you know really not not
giving any good reason why she would
want to be the leader of any group that
was uh had anything to do with a con
seditious conspiracy but i guess my
question is she has now said she's not
the leader she's she was she is
she stepped down after stewart's night
bill the first time
uh said that it didn't think it was
going to be a long haul she's uh was
denying having had a personal
relationship with him now way earlier i
meant to bring it up is
early on
from basically from right after the
beginning when it first started to kind
of slide into being a militia lots of
people inside of keepers would have been
um
completely open to insurrection and
insurgency if they felt like it was
necessary or justified
it's just that the 10 standing orders
are diametrically opposed to
michael flynn was advocating for while
he was meeting with trump behind closed
doors okay that right there should have
been the part that put the kebabs on not
necessarily
carrying out insurrection in itself
but
the legal mechanism behind it and the
people involved
that would have been unpalatable to all
those keepers
what was your question gabe oh no well
earlier you mentioned that we actually
mentioned the truckers and you said you
had a take on that so i'd be curious to
know what that is you know
too far off topic but i figured it would
be worth it
my take um is that
this is the next round of
the
first draft
of the moga rally in dc from like the
old screen caps that were circulating
for their original on parlor
for their original plan which was just a
wall of bodies to shut off washington dc
shut it down only permit
the correct republican lawmakers through
and not to allow anyone from the
democratic party or anything called
rhinos in or out of dc at all and any um
action by the police to move them or
break up the protests would be the
instant start of a hot civil war you
know that brings up i i can't remember
who was in the video in the last week or
so but they were saying they need to
shut down capitals and
and um in california capitals in new
york the washington d.c i feel like
they've been saying that for for a while
right they always whenever they're
talking about shutting down to like show
you know who's who's in power because i
feel like i've heard that before it was
like the state capitals is what they
want to shut down in order to force the
hand well yeah they did it when they did
didn't they do this um um you know after
after the january 16th well they did it
before they tried a couple different
little rounds right yeah you know during
the stop the steel kind of campaign and
then then of course the insurrection
happened and then they tried it a couple
different times of their capitals um
because there was different events like
the my pillow guy was
was propagating you know there was the
march fourth thing and then the
september 89th and i am [ __ ] it's hard
to tell with with mike lindell at this
point like where he moves the goalpost
but as he was moving the goal post you
know they would have try to have
different events and this sort of thing
and i think i think maybe you're right
that they're you know this is kind of
pre-planning and they're using canada
and a foreign country type thing um to
try to determine
they're figuring out um what services
they can use that will
um transfer donations without blocking
them that's what now gives send go is
going to be
the mainstay nobody's going to bother
with upon me or anything anymore they're
try work they've worked out how to keep
people off of their zello channels so
they don't
well
they haven't figured out they haven't
figured out twitter we're talking about
this today you're talking about the ram
ranchers resistance which is
absolutely
[ __ ] incredible and honestly maybe
the ram ranchers are the
you know the anti-oath keepers at this
point you know i don't know i'm just the
real real patriots in this situation
right exactly well you know
it actually was a good resistance and it
was one of the best um non-violent
protests that we've seen in a long time
have you have you seen the some of the
videos that were made by the militiamen
inside the malheur wildlife refuge and
people would send them dildos and like
55 gallon drums yes that one i do
remember that amazon order that came
together yeah they would make because
they were asking for
their standoff and they would make
videos posing with all the [ __ ] people
sent them talking about how awful it was
people were doing this
that would very much remind me of that
and i just love that um ram ranch is
culturally relevant again i feel like
it's heyday was way too short
right we got right they were like uh i
think i posted on twitter somewhere
there was like a
there are like a bunch of like
fandom specific parody versions there's
a warhammer 40 000 version
of the rainbow song which is about as
homoerotic as you can possibly
not to plug it too much but i actually
put a ram uh a ram ranch resistance 2022
um t-shirt so if anyone
on the merch store so if anyone wants to
go grab a a ram
ranch resistant i think it's hilarious
we watched the video today where it's
inside one of these yellow kind of radio
rooms or whatever the hell it is and um
they start playing the song the the the
song and they're talking about you know
these guys giving fellatio to each other
and stuff and that yeah of course
it is your it is your program
huh what's that if you if you want you
can say sucking [ __ ] if you want yeah
i mean sucking [ __ ] fellatio you know
i'm trying to i'm trying to keep it
clean for the children to go to jesus
christ
they're gonna take you out of the
children and family well you know
we're we're not in the children and
family category for sure now i do we do
have several several videos that are
that are marked adult only but you know
i i'm not sure there's no nudity in them
i'm just not sure
but but we did play we did play the song
today or part of it right so we played
the sucking cox part on the show today
so no this you can you can say sucking
[ __ ] on the tony michael's podcast that
is that is absolutely especially when
you're referring to the ram ranchers
resistance
i feel like i should i feel like in
addition
i feel like though i wanna i feel like
ram ranchers it's like the resistance
tour
and then you just gotta have to put a
bunch of cities oh yeah yeah yeah sure
sure and where are they and you know
what it might be a short tour like it
could be like ottawa and then just like
ottawa right and then maybe no shorty no
pun intended
on the short tour thing everything else
has been canceled that's why well dakota
i really appreciate you coming and
joining us again and we really want to
have you back as this as this news
develops so if there's new news next
week or the week after uh please please
come back and we'll talk to you more
because i really uh the other thing i'd
like to do
and i know the audience wants to know
more about the bundy ranch and some of
that stuff you know some of the
specifics that happened that with the
oak keepers um and kind of do a deep
dive into that so we'd really like to
have you here with that kind of stuff
too
is there anywhere where the are there is
there anywhere that you know of where
people saved all those keepers videos
because they had a youtube video where
they had a round table discussion
going out over there after action the
oath keepers after action report from
their involvement in bundy ranch i'd
know but we can probably try to dig
something up for you if you'd like i
tried
for you an extensive video that went
into a lot of stuff that is not widely
known
and it shows like the dysfunctional
internal politics of the militia
movement and like showcases it in a
really interesting way cool yeah
well maybe
we'll chat about that um offline and
we'll we'll uh we'll try to see if we
can dig that up and then maybe maybe
we'll have you back in the next couple
weeks and we'll talk about that
specifically because i know the audience
um is interested in in that type of uh
content of breaking down exactly what
all this stuff means because it is kind
of confusing like even the qrf and some
of the language the stack a lot of
people aren't part of that
militia culture so they don't they don't
understand what that stuff means right
they just they just don't that's why
even some of those videos uh seeing the
oath keepers at the capitol in those
uniforms makes it confusing where they
almost look like they're the actual
military and that is that is the intent
that's right
exactly exactly so thanks dakota for
joining us
in the especially in the green with the
patches they look at first class like
they could be state like state police
absolutely
trust this person especially the way
they they have helmets on and some of
the gear um it looks you know super
quote-unquote official um you know but
rather that
intention or not it seems intentional to
me um you're saying it's intentional um
knowing knowing the militias thanks for
joining us thanks for giving us your
insight on the hearing today um and if
we have more news we'll bring you back
thanks dakota i appreciate it everyone
stick around we'll be right back after
this message